مساء الخير واصل الجنيه المصري ارتفاعه
امام الدولار الشهر الخامس على التوالي
ليسجل الدولار سطاشر دينيه تسعه وسبعين
مقارنه بسبعطاشر دينيه و 80 قرش في يناير
الماضي ما يعني انه قد فقد نحو خمسه وسته
من عشره من في سؤالين الناس بيطرح وهم ايه
سبب هذا التراجع في الدولار امام الجنيه
والسؤال الثاني الكليه المصري رايح على
فين يرتفع ولا ينخفض اجابه السؤال الاول
بسيطه المفروض يعني ليه الدولار بين خفض
والدعم الكينيه في ظل نظام المفروض ان
تكون الاجابه ببساطه مساله عرض وطلب توفر
معروض كافي من الدولار فان خافت اما مدري
ليه الناس لا تتقبل هذه الاجابه وتشعر ان
هناك شيئا مريبا الاجابه ببساطه لان الناس
اعتادت على مدى سنوات طويله منذ الخمسينات
والى الان ان الدولار بالضروره يرتفع امام
الجنيه في
الامر الثاني انه كل التوقعات او معظم
التوقعات من بنوك الاستثمار وبيوت الخبره
داخل وخارج مصر كانت تتوقع ان الجنيه امام
الدولار على المدى المتوسط والقريب
والبعيد وبعض هذه البنوك اللي بتقدم
استشارتها مدفوعه الاجر الى بعض
المستثمرين توقعت انه الدولار ليصل الى
ثمنطاشر ونص فيه فيه جون او يونيو ال 2019
وفي اه يونيو البعض او في اه في الشهور
التاليه في عام 2019 يسجل في نهايتها اه
تعطي شويه
ويتجاوز العشرين في الفين وعشرين
على الاقل حتى الان اسباب كثيره جدا لكن
اقدر اقول لكم ببساطه ان توقع سعر الصرف
في اي دوله
[موسيقى]
وزي ما بتقول الدكتوره سنو استاذه
الاقتصاد المرموقه صندوق النقد الدولي
الذي يضع توقعات لكل اقتصادات العالم
بيحكم عن ان يمرر نفسه في توقع سعر صرفه
محدد لعمله ما لانها تخضع لعوامل كثيره
يعني الوصول سعر الصرف المعدل معين يخضع
لاعتبارات كثيره مش كلها يمكن التنبؤ فيها
بدقه اذا كانت التنبؤ بسعر الصرف عملات
مختلفه امر صعب في الغالب ابدينا هو بيبقى
شبه مستحيل لو ان البنك المركزي احاطوا
بسياج كبيره من السريه واعتبره سر الحربين
كما يحدث في مصر وطبعا هو اللي هو كل الحق
في ذلك في النهايه انا اصفي عندي سعر صرف
وصل اه اه اه ال ال في اول خمس او ست شهور
من 2019 الى مستوى لن يتوقعه معظم الناس
عدد محدود جدا توقعوا ان ترتفع على عكس
التيار العام اللي كانت بتوقع الجنيه
انخفض واحد من هؤلاء الناس اقتصادي مصري
الدكتور باسم امر بيعمل في احد المؤسسات
الماليه الغربيه الكبيره
اكبر توقع ارتفاع الجنيه المصري منذ يناير
انه المرتفع وتوقع انه يسجل سطاشر سبعين
ثمانين اه يعني زي ما وصل اليه المصري
تقريبا لما سالت الدكتور باسبي انت توقعت
على عكس الاتجاه اللي انه هو حاول يقرا
الحكومه او البنك المركزي عاوز ايه عشان
نفهم البنك المركزي عاوز ايه لازم نحكي
القسم الاول اللي توضح لنا
ارتفع في الفتره الماضيه
الحكومه او البنك المركزي الدوله يعني
وعلى راسها البنك المركزي اللي هو المسؤول
عن السياسه النقديه امامه معاقبه ومن تحدي
كبير هذا التحدي الكبير ان بعد تقريبا ست
سنوات من انطلاق برنامج الاصلاح الاقتصادي
فيها اجراءات كثيره جدا
المناخ والبنيه التحتيه ل اه
نمو اقتصادي وانتعاشه اقتصاديه امامهم
مشكله كبيره وهو انخفاض مستوى الاستثمار
سواء الاجنبي المباشر او الاستثمار المحلي
عندهم الهدف الوقت ان يزود جاذبيه او يزود
جذب الاستثمارات المحليه والاجنبيه بس اذا
ما بيحصلش بالقدر الكافي اللي ما بيحصل شي
بالقدر الكافي لانه تكلفه الاستثمار في
المصدر وارتفع تكلفه التمويل غاليه ولا
تكلفه التمويل غاليه لانه سعر الفائده
مرتفع احنا بنقول سعر الفائده على مدار
ثلاث سنين اللي فات دول من حوالي سطاشر
عشرين في المائه يعني انت بتاخذ من البنك
اكثر من سطاشر وبتوصل الى عشرين في المائه
عشان تاخذ قرض من البيت لما اي مستثمر
طبعا لما بيقول الفائده عليها معناها انه
المستثمر بيجي يسال نفسه السؤال ايه هو
المشروع لنا ممكن اعمله وبعدما ادفع حوالي
عشرين في المائه فائده للبنك واه ادفع
تكاليف الانتاج والامور
معنى كده انه من الصعب جدا ان اليه مشروع
يحقق لها مشرف مع مستويات سعر الفائده
المرتفعه جدا حتى لو ان المستثمر مش ياخذ
قرض من البنك سعر الفائده يعتبر البنش
مارك او ال يعني المقياس اللي الواحد يحسب
عليه تكلفه الاستثمار فهو لا ياخذ فلوس
مثلا من مستثمرين اصحابها او يعني من
الموارد الذاتيه اي حديديه الفلوس الدين
الفلوس واعمل مخاطره ولا حط فلوسه في
البنك واخذ 18 20 في المائه
دلوقتي العائق امام الاستثمار او او
العائق الاساسي امام الاستثمار في مصر هو
سعر الفائده المرتفع ومادام الاستثمار مش
هيدي مش ايفو بشفافيه
انذاك ولا فيه نمو ولا في تشغيل ولا في
ارتفاع المستوى المعيشي كل حاجه هتبقى
مشلوله يبقى هدف الحكومه انا انا سعر
الفائده بحيث انا اشجع الاستثمار وبالتالي
اقدر العجله الاقتصاد صدور هو مش قادر يه
خفت سعر الفائده
ببساطه لان سعر الفائده
مرتبط ب معدل التضخم وما هو معدل التضخم
في حلقه سابقه هو الارتفاع في المعدل
العام او المؤشر العام للاسعار
احنا عندنا صحيح التضخم انخفض انما انخفض
من حوالي ثلاثين في المائه في اول 2017
انخفضت الوقتي بحوالي 13 14 في المائه
فليست معدل عالي الحكومه عاوزه نزلوا الى
ما دون العشره في المائه
وعاوزه
عشان لجذب الاستثمار وما قادر سعر الفائده
لان التضخم مرتفعه طيب لما يكون التضخم
مرتفع
يتمركز يعمل ايه علشان يخفضوا قدام وسيله
من اثنين ما فيش فيهم حل ثالث بالنسبه
للبنك المركزي اول وسيله انه يرفع تعرفين
لما يرفع سعر الفائده يحصل انه هذه
السيوله اللي في السوق الناس تبعه وتاخذ
اه يعني مقابل الاعداء مع انه في العائد
اللي هي دولها البنك وبالتالي بفلوسها
للبنوك بيزيد الادخار لما يزيد الادخار اه
في الحاله هذه السيوله تسحب من السوق تبقى
قدره الناس على الشرقي السوء بيهدى
وبالتالي التضخم بين خفض الحل الاول ان بس
مش وارد لانه سعر الفائده وهذه مرتفع وهو
الاستثمار في مصر يعاني من ارتفاع سعر
الفائده يبقى ما فيش قدام البنك المركزي
تغيير الحل الثاني
كان يقدر نفس النتيجه وهو محاوله السماح
للعمله المحليه بالارتفاع يحصل ايه لما
العمله الوطنيه ترتفع يحصل انه في بلد
بيعتمد على الاستيراد بشكل كبير في مصر
وكل الدول العربيه مصر مثلا الميزان
التجاري فيها اللي
وارداتها او صادرتها من السلع مصر بدستور
ثلاثه امثال ما تصدر وبالتالي الصدر
الخدمات طبعا ال ال اه احنا ب نعتمد بشكل
كبير جدا على الواردات سواء في السلع
الاستهلاكيه او في السلع الوسيطه لاي
عمليه الانتاج المحلي
لو احنا قدرنا انجليس ارتفع امام الدولار
الواردات ال كثيره جدا اللي تيجي وقيمتها
السلع بس حوالي سبعه وستين مليار دولار ها
تنخفض ولما تنخفض اسعارها يحصل ايه التضخم
ينخفض ولما التضخم ينخفض يبقى في الحاله
التي يقدر ينزل سعر الفائده ولما ينزل سعر
الفائده يقدر انه يشجع المستثمر انه يقترب
من البنك بدل ما بيقدر ثمنطاشر وعشرين في
المائه هيدا ممكن يقترض بنسبه تسعه وعشره
في المائه او سبعه في المائه كل مكان ال
كل ما يزود عمليه الاستثمار
الهدف الاساسي هو
البنك المركزي انه
الجنيه على اساس انه يقدر يساعده في
التحكم في التضخم وبالتالي زياده سعر
الفائده طيب قرش في الاول بالشكل واه كانت
المشكله يعني تحلت من بدري ببساطه لانه لم
يكن في مقدور البنك المركزي السماح
بارتفاع سعر الجنيه وسعر الجانب يرتفع
الزاي في نظام معين بانه العرض والطلب انه
يكون عندهم
الدولارات من مصادر مختلفه بشكل وفير يؤدي
الوفره في المعروض فهي انخفض طبعا الحسنه
الوفره اي وحصل توفره نسبه من المصادر
الدولاريه المختلفه لمصر
على مدار الشهور الماضيه مش بس سته شهور
دور وقبل يوم شويه
المصادر الدولاريه اللي موجوده في مصر 5
زائر 1 يعني ما اقدر اقول 6 او 5
15 الاولانيين دول لا يترتب عن
المصدر الثالث مولد للدين الخمسه اللي ما
بينهم ديون اللي هو الاستثمار الاجنبي
المباشر
والسياحه و تحويلات المصريين العاملين فى
الخارج
بالاضافه الى اي منح تحصل عليها الحكومه
المصريه
العقد قناه السويس والصادرات المصريه
الدول
الخمسه الغير مو دين دين وعندنا
المصدر الثالث اللي هو الاقتراض سواء
الاقتراض طويل الامل زي اللي احنا اخذناه
من صندوق النقد الدولي اللي دانا حوالي
اربعه مليار دولار في ست شهور يعني من
يناير الى الان الدفعه الخمسه والدفع
السته او ال ال الاستثمار فى ادوات الدين
او الاموال الساخره اللي حنا تكلمنا عنها
قبل كده اللي الناس يحاولوا يشتروا الديون
المصريه مقابل الدولار وده حجمه في مصر
وصل لغايه ابريل اللي فات حوالي سطاشر
مليار الخلاصه عشان تفاصيل كثيره انه
الزاد المعروض من الدولار في معظم هذه
المصادر بشكل ملموس وقف زرقه من واحد
وسبعين مليار دولار في 2017 الاثنين
وثمانين مليار دولار في 2018 ومن المتوقع
انه في نهايه العام حالي يصل الرقم الى
خمسه وتسعين اه اه مائه مليار دولار يبقى
حصل عنده معروضه وبالتالي يمكن البنك
المركزي م ما لم يكن من كرم من قبل وهو
السماح الجنيه المصري بالارتفاع يسمح لي
ان البنك بيتدخل بداته يشتري ويبيع بحيث
انه يسمح للدولار انه يرتفع او ان خافت
وبالتالي هو اصبح عنده القدره دلوقتي مع
تكون احتياطات
اه نقديه بلغت حوالي اربعه واربعين مليار
دولار في البنك المركزي المصري انه يسمح
للكليب الارتفاع وبالفعل ارتفع الجنيه
حوالي خمسه وسته من عشره طيب يبقى ان ده
علشان طبعا فيه نسبه مش كل الكلام فيه ناس
يهمها انا معي اعمل المتاخرات
رقم
مائه الف دولار خمسين الف دولار ثلاثين
الف دولار من اصحاب المدخرات الصغيره
والمتوسطه الا القليل اللي عندك كثير عندك
قدره انه يعني شو عنده القدره انه يتصرف
يستشير بيوت خبره كثير اصحاب المدخرات
الصغيره والمتوسطه بالدولار لهم هو الكليه
رايح فين
المهمه جدا بعد ما فهمت الاسباب ليه
الكنيه ارتفع انك تعرف معلومه تانيه مهمه
جدا انك ما تسال شيء اي حدود قد اجبت بثقه
الجينيه يروح فين بالضبط الحربي لونس عرفت
وبتقدر تحقق من مطارات ضخمه جدا
والبنك المركزي يصرح لحد ما تصرف المعلومه
اللي جنيه بالضبط حتى البنك المركزي نفسه
او المسؤولين فيه بيبقى عارفين هما حطين
اتجاهين لكن بيقدرش يتحكم مائه في المائه
في الى جنيها يوصل الى حد معين في وقت
معين لانها خاضعا لاعتبارات لا تقع كلها
تحت سيطره
وبالتالي عندما تكشف كثير في انك تسال من
تعتقد انه هم فاهمين وتطمئني للاجابه
وتبني عليها التوقعات قد تصدق وقد
اختار بدليل انه كل بنوك الاستثمار
المحترمه في مصر وخارج مصر توقعت شيء وحدث
شيء اخر الا عدد محدود جدا جدا منهم زي
اللي انا اشرت اليه وبالتالي انت لو انت
عاوز اجابه بسيطه مش حتلاقي لو عاوز اجابه
اوسع يبقى معدل التضخم في ال مصر رايح في
طلب التضخم مرتفع طبعا سعر الفائده حيفضل
رغبه البنك المركزي في المرحله الحاليه في
الغالب هي محاوله السماح للكليه بالارتفاع
لاحظ انه الطريقه عليها قيود
يخلي الجينيه خفض ارتفع لانه لا يرتفع
قويه يعني وصل بقه اللي تحت ال 15 و 12 و
اتجاهنا للعشره ده يناقض كل
الفلسفه اللبناني عليها برنامج الاصلاح
الاقتصادي اللي كان الايام على اه اولا هو
معندوش القدره الى ان ما عندوش الموارد
الدولاريه الوفيره مازالت مصره
النسبه يعني زياده معقوله من الدولارات
لزياده وثيره بدليل ان ما زال فيه قيود
على شراء الدولار فى البنوك بيحط عليك
قيود ويسال كنت عاوز هو لازم تاخذ من بنتك
مش متعدد في اي مكان فما زال حتى الان
الوضع ما هو اشمل يعني مش مطمئن جدا واضاف
ان كثير من المصادر لنا انتهى كلها ممكن
تتغير بين لحظه واخرى لا قدر الله لو اي
عمل يعني اه يعني اي عمليه ارهابيه لا قدر
الله
في مصر نسال الله الا تحدث ابدا تاثر على
السياحه بشكل كبير وبالتالي تغير كل
الموازين وكل الحسابات اي اي حاجه تتعلق
في حدث دولي اثر على حجم التجاره الدوليه
هي اثر على عوائد قناه السويس وهكذا فداء
واحد انه غير مطمئن انه المصادر الدولاريه
التي لديه يمكن ان تمكنه من التحكم في سعر
الجديد بيشكل طويله الامد او بشكل كبير
انه يرفعوا بشكل كبير اثنين
انه ليس من مصلحته المدنيه ارتفع ايضا
بشكل كبير جدا وهذا ما كنت عاوز اقول
لحضراتكم السياسه اللي قامت عليها برنامج
الاصلاح الاقتصادي
وهي بوساطه الجنيه انخفضت يزود الصادرات
المصريه لانه معنى كده ان المستورد اللي
مع دولار برا يشتري عدد وحدات اكثر من اي
من مصر زي ال المده في نفس الدولار بدل ما
كان يشتري الما يشتري الامين بالدولار
وبالتالي او كما اصدرت الامر التالي انه
السياحه زادت مؤخرا احد عوامل زياده
السياحه مؤخرا رغم الاجواء المضطربه
اقليميا هو انخفاض قيمه الجنيه في الساعه
بيجي المصري ويستمتع بخدمات اكثر بنفس
الدولار ال الاموال الساخنه او الاستثمار
فى ادوات الدين المصريه زادت بسبب ارتفاع
سعر الفائده الجنيه ارتفع
واقدر هو ياللي للتضخم عن طريق رفع سعر
الجنيه
سعر الفائده برده يغري وين ال الراجل اللي
جاي يستثمر في ادوات الدين معنى كده انه
رفع الكينيه خفض الفائده لو تم بشكل كبير
ياثر على العائد اه على العوائل من
الصادرات والعوائل من السياحه والعوائل من
الاموال الساخنه وبالتالي حصل نقص في
المعروض من الدولار معنا كده انه كل
سياسه رفع الكينيه ايضا عليها قيود والبنك
المركزي بيحاول يوصل الى سعر يتوازن فيه
كل الاعتبارات باعتبار انه يخلي الصادرات
المصريه والسياحه والاستثمار فى ادوات
الدين من الاجانب جاذبه وفي نفس الوقت ما
يخليش الواردات سعرها مرتفع او منخفض
قليلا بحيث ينزل التضخم قليلا ايه هو
السعاده هي المساله اللي هو البنك المركزي
يعرف وبيحاولوا واصلين لكن من الصعب جدا
ان اي حد يتنبا به بشكل اه يعني دقيق
وحاسم
الايام اللي جايه تشهد زياده في ال في
المحروقات يعني الدعم ال وبالتالي التضخم
عايزين والبنك المركزي يلاقي نفسه عنده
صعوبه في السيطره على التضخم ويبتدي هنا
يوازن يعمل ايه
يرفع سعر الفائده
مساله الاستثمار واللي يحاول انه يزود
الجنيه على اساس يقلل التضخم الهدف اللي
هو عاوز
ب خفض التضخم وبالتالي تشجيع الاستثمار
البنك المركزي قدام مهمه صعبه والجنيه
التنبؤ بسعر في ظل هذه العوامل المختلفه
مساله في غايه الصعوبه اشكركم والى لقاء
اخر باذن الله
[موسيقى]